foreign
this is the Reuben report and uh we
didn't do a cold open for you today
because it's a somber October 14th 2022
because the economy is in the [ __ ]
and that's what we're going to be
covering today I hope you've subscribed
and tap the notification Bell wherever
you're watching the program uh guys the
theme today is yeah the inflation
situation the economic situation that
whole money thing that kind of runs the
whole show it is not in particularly
good shape at the moment and uh Joe
Biden he is not helping uh so we're
going to get to a little bit of that and
then we have a Reuben report dot
locals.com q a so yeah let's talk about
inflation we've got a quote here from
Bloomberg
the core Consumer Price Index which
excludes food and energy increased from
6.6 percent from a year ago the highest
level since 1992 Labor Department data
showed Thursday from a month earlier the
core CPI climbed 0.6 percent for a
second month the overall CPI increased
0.4 last month and was up 8.2 percent
from a year earlier the media forecasts
in a Bloomberg survey of economists had
called for a 0.4 percent monthly rise in
the core and a 0.2 percent in the
overall measure okay so if you're not
big on economics if you didn't do
economics 101 in uh in college the point
is that these numbers are not good
inflation is bad we technically were in
a recession already and now we're about
to enter this third quarter of recession
even though they have suddenly redefined
what a recession means a recession
always before this Administration and
the nonsensical media yeah that is part
of the this Administration a recession
always was two negative quarters of GDP
right gross domestic product uh now we
are in Q3 it is negative we're
technically in Q4 we just closed create
Q3 and it is negative so the September
CPI inflation data that broke yesterday
that's what I'm reading to you there it
ain't good that's that's the general
point I don't like we get lost in all
these little percentages uh but the
point is we've known this was coming
right this is not shocked no one's
watching this right now like oh my God
things aren't going great uh but the
Administration has been lying about
what's going on for quite some time I
really doubt that we're going to see an
inflationary cycle the most economic
analysts that believe that it will have
a temporary transitory impact faster
than expected increase in some of those
prices is actually a good sign
overwhelming consensus is going to pop
up a little bit and then go back down
no one's talking about this great great
view this is something that will uh
settle down transitory and the data
shows that most of the price increases
we've seen are were expected and and
expected to be temporary there's nobody
suggesting the non-sect inflation on the
way it's highly unlikely that it's going
to be long-term inflation that's going
to get out of hand I don't know anybody
who's worried about inflation over the
last couple of months we actually saw it
trended downward President Biden's Chief
of Staff Ron claim enthusiastically
retweeted an economist who had said in
part most of the economic problems we're
facing inflation Supply chains Etc are
high class problems what is the grand
home plan to increase oil production in
America
God that is hilarious well the number
one thing that the president can do is
help get coveted under control uh that
we know is the root cause of inflation
okay so they locked us down they crushed
the economy they've hit the energy
sector they're going after fossil fuels
they spend money completely out of
control and then of course they blame
everyone else or somehow the media will
have you tricked into thinking this was
all the Republicans fault and again
Republicans vote for a lot of this
nonsense but they certainly are not in
charge right now here is video from two
days ago uh here is Joseph R Biden
talking to Democrat activist Jake Tapper
on CNN about his inflation reduction act
and how it's helping we we passed so
much legislation that significantly
makes a makes a point about you know for
example the American Rescue plan the
legislation to deal with inflation the
the inflation act again as I brought up
the other day he calls it accidentally
the inflation act which is actually what
it is if you just throw money at
something and you put a nice bumper
sticker on it it doesn't mean that it
actually does the thing inflation would
be going down if the inflation act
reduction act that they spent all the
money on was working but actually we
found out today that inflation increased
by 0.4 percent last month uh that
reminded me we of a video we've showed
you a couple times that I just I just
think this was this was just funny
here's treasury secretary Janet Yellen a
couple months ago and she's got hope
there's no question that we have huge
inflation pressures that inflation is
really our top economic problem at this
point and that it's critical that we
address it so I do expect I do expect
inflation to remain high although I very
much hope that it will be coming down
now I just love that it's like yeah it's
a real problem but I certainly and I'm
the treasury secretary over here you
know I've got an abacus at my desk I
certainly hope that that that doesn't
happen here she is two days ago despite
all of the current numbers
we still see the impact of
covet in China and the slowdown in
Chinese growth and with high inflation
and tightening monetary policy in many
Advanced countries
Emerging Markets from really all of
these factors are suffering many
stresses so there's a lot to talk about
but from the perspective of the United
States I think the United States is
doing very well
well in July she had hope and now she's
telling us that things are doing well
again this is one of those things where
you don't really need to dive into the
numbers you don't have to sit there with
the percentages and this and that do you
feel like you have more money now that
the economy is safe that you can go out
and spend the same amount you would of a
year ago and get the same amount of
stuff does any of that feel right to you
we all know that it ain't right you know
go try to buy a new car and and then
because of the supply chain it's
actually sometimes now used cars are
more expensive than new cars because at
least you can get the new the used car
now like there's a whole series of
problems here but these people have hope
and the real question what it all boils
down to is do you think these are the
people who should be in charge of this
do you think these are the people who
can Steward us out of this or are these
are the people who dug us into it that
really is what it's all about and on
that note let's get to a Reuben report
Community Q a uh Kathy says how are the
kiddos how much have things changed with
two instead of one so yeah we had Luke
basically a week ago seven days old as
of today
he's good you know it's funny so they're
they're two months to the day different
age-wise so uh Justin was born on August
6th and Luke was born on October 6th and
it's wild how much a kid grows in two
months because Justin and Justin's kind
of big anyway like he was born big and
he's big and he's eaten a ton he's in
like the 86 percentile in in height and
weight
pediatrician's very happy with him very
happy with Luke too but you know just
when I'm holding them both together it's
like wow I cannot believe that this was
this not too long ago uh their
temperament we're getting a ton of
smiles out of Justin now like just ton
he just lights up when I go in the room
which is awesome and uh Luke is his he's
just soft and gentle you know he's just
in those first couple days right he's
still in that first couple day life so
it's a lot of sleeping curling up in a
little ball but they're good they're
good and uh the diapers are being
changed the pacifiers are being washed
Etc Rose says with everything going on
in our country being a total mess from
inflation to Crime to our borders Etc
and Libs showing no sign of slowing down
or reversing course what kind of stunt
are they planning on pulling to throw
this thing they have to realize this is
all very deeply unpopular with the
American people yet they don't seem to
care you know that reminds me of the uh
AOC video that we showed you yesterday
where her own constituents virtually
nobody shows up to listen into her but
then her own constituents people who
were saying I believed in you are now
completely turning on her in this case
it was because of the the Russia Ukraine
situation but it had obviously a little
bit to do with the economy as well and
people are waking up to it you know the
moms that are like no no no no no you
can't come for our kids anymore and
that's why School boards now are
shifting where you're getting more
conservative leaning parents it's not
even conservative as I always say it's
just sort of sane
parents that are getting on school
boards instead of letting everything be
ransacked by the radicals so the
question always is and it's a good one
and I don't know exactly what the answer
is uh you know it's like what will they
do right before the election does the
war go hot so we all feel like we can't
vote for different people we need the
people who are wrecking everything to
stay it'll be too risky if we get new
people
covid
monkey pox
who the hell knows you know just like
who knows and that's why it is vital
even if you're here in Florida where you
know DeSantis is going to crush Charlie
Crist he won by about 30 000 votes last
time basically less than one percent
it's like he needs to win by 10 15 like
run up the score destroy these people
destroy these people let's as I keep
saying let's just put them in that rear
view mirror and let's build a wide tent
Republican party and then f'd out of the
ashes of the destroyed Democrat Party
maybe the ghost of JFK shows up maybe
they hand it to Tulsi and then we can
have the debates right about the Second
Amendment and about abortion and
government spending with the same party
on both sides that's where we're at
that's what we got to do but yes they
can come up with anything proudest mom
says what's the weekly bill for the
diapers and formula at the Reuben
household and how many bottles are
prepared and diapers change per week I
mean it is a lot of diapers and it's a
lot of bottle goals and there's
pacifiers everywhere we have little
buckets of pacifiers in different rooms
I try not to go right to the pacifier
there's a baby crying I try to do
everything I can before we go right to
the pacifier Justin actually on day one
like an hour into his existence on this
planet he was sucking his thumb he
hasn't done it since but Justin has
never sucked his thumb little Insider
info for you on that uh but yeah look
you're feeding these kids uh Luke
especially now at the early stages
you're feeding them basically every
three hours Justin is now stretching his
nighttime sleeping but it's a lot of
diapers we got the Diaper Genie there's
you know Butt Paste and all this stuff
it's so it's yes it's racking up in
price but we're using glass bottles
because they generally are thought of as
a little bit better and you get the
anti-colic thing you don't want them
swallowing air and all that stuff Cheryl
says what do you think is the likelihood
of Tulsi just throwing her hat in the
presidential ring for 2024 if you
believe she will run do you think she'll
run as a Republican or an independent
which gives are the best chance look I
truly do not know I'm sure we'll get her
on the show soon to you know unpack some
of what's going on here I don't know
that she even wants to be in politics in
a traditional sense like that I really
don't she may want to go more into media
she just launched a podcast
I think she has all sorts of other
opportunities
um would she want to jump in immediately
as president
I don't know and again and I also don't
know if it would be Republican
independent whatever look my position
you know my position on this already the
Republicans are not perfect but there is
a malleability there and there is a wide
tent thing there that she can clearly
fit into right she can clearly fit into
that and say she would be on the more
socially liberal side of it whether it
came to abortion or gay marriage or
whatever and the ship has sailed on some
of these things anyway but she could fit
into it it's why it's why if Bill Maher
could get over some of the stuff I think
he could fit into it too right
but let's just put that aside for a
second
um I don't know what she wants to do my
look look if we were at a 2024 situation
if you watching this right now and you
may not agree with Tulsi on a lot of
stuff if you heard that it was going to
be DeSantis and Tulsi
that's pretty solid like how much more
solid would it get than that how how
much more airtight how much sort of wide
tent and effective and a caring about
America and let's put some disagreements
aside and like feel like the stewards of
this country are are the ones that we
deserve uh I think that would be pretty
solid uh tappy chef says what was your
first car Dave mine was a 64 Chevy Coupe
DeVille my dad gave me on my 16th
birthday costing 400 bucks in 77 wow
that's awesome uh my first car was my
grandma's I think it was a 79 oh man I'm
aging myself guys this is what year were
you guys what year were you born 92
to Jesus 2 000 my first car was my
grandma's uh Buick Regal this thing was
a behemoth if you want to put a picture
of a Buick Regal in you can put a
picture of a Buick Regal this thing was
a big blue Buick Regal my grandma and
grandpa my grandpa had already passed
but my grandparents had that thing for
you know a couple years before that it
may it may have been earlier even than
79 or something and it had sort of old
person scent and the ceiling was caving
in a little bit you could like push
holes in the ceiling because the like
foam was no good anymore and it was big
and I remember you're not like turning
the steering wheel it was like trying to
turn the Titanic the iceberg we gotta ah
yeah that was my first car I love that
car I really did Lawrence says do you
think it's possible that zelenski is
blackmailing the Biden Administration
holding to incriminating evidence of
questionable past Financial dealings in
order to be in order to secure continued
support some powerful people would have
an interest in keeping such information
Secret
let's put it this way I don't think
that's completely off the table what was
Hunter Biden doing as a consultant for a
Ukrainian Energy company
while he was also a crack addict
why did we hide the laptop why did
Twitter make sure we couldn't see any of
that stuff is why does it seem like the
world just pours tons of money into
Ukraine and uses it as this place that
we must pour a ton of money and we
cannot get receipts and we don't know
who's doing what but we like something
does not seem right so it feels like
it's like a money laundering operation I
don't know exactly but yes I don't think
you're let's put this way I don't think
you're a crazy conspiracy theorist for
that one uh roll with me here Phoenix
Lauren says the grand plan what is your
vision of locals for the next 10 years
well I'm really thrilled obviously with
what has happened with locals and and
the community our Reuben report
Community is really thriving and that's
where I'm posting pictures of the babies
and I communicate with you guys in a
more personal way and it's really the
only place that I personally respond to
anyone or any of that stuff but
obviously we've merged with Rumble and
we really I'm telling you guys like
we're really trying to build that
parallel economy we're trying to build
the pipes so that one day uh if YouTube
just says no more of this nonsense Dave
or if Twitter says you're out or
Facebook or whatever that we have a home
and I have a home that they cannot take
away right now I have that if the whole
freaking thing went down today you know
they pulled the Amazon AWS they press
the button or they flip the touch screen
whatever it might be it's like I'm gonna
still be okay almost everyone else uh
that you watch on YouTube or you're
watching on Facebook whatever it might
be is not okay I I have a bajillion
meetings with these people talking about
the payment processor issue because you
know there's all this crazy stuff with
PayPal now and we're trying to solve as
many of the problems as possible this
was not something that I intended to do
so I would say in 10 years what I would
what I would want in 10 years is that
Rumble locals is basically the sort of
new Hub of the Internet it's a new place
where you can get all sorts of services
not only video and community and chat
and live stream and all that stuff but
that we have email we have payment
processors we have chat and all of the
stuff so that you can do what you want
to online and if you break the law then
you're in trouble with the law you know
it's like it really is as simple as that
at an ideal level at the technical level
it's very hard to build all of this
stuff and it takes a lot of money and it
takes a lot of expertise but we're doing
the best we can and uh I would say we're
doing even better than we can probably
to some extent and and now that Rumble
is public and listed on NASDAQ you know
it's a public company Free Speech has
gone public that that's a beautiful
thing Reid says hey Dave Bill Maher has
a problem with Trump as do many of us
have you ever considered asking him one
of prager's classic questions regarding
personal lives of politicians that is if
you had cancer would you choose a nice
but average oncologist or a very skilled
and successful oncologist who can be a
total [ __ ] you know I wanted to pose
this to him I really did you know you
may remember number I had Dennis on a
week or two ago so I had just spoke to
Dennis and Dennis and I speak all the
time and I thought that really is it
because Bill he's getting there I want
to give him the room to get there I
think we started something really good
in terms of conversation and going
forward that's really been the reaction
from everybody hot damn to people who
disagree or came to a final conclusion
are still came to different conclusions
at the end are still trying to work
through it like how cool is that like
that's the way we all used to be right
that was what the dream was all about
that we could agree to disagree and
still you know think that the country's
good and fight for what we believe in
and all of those things and break bread
with people
um so I would have liked to have asked
him that you know we bounced in and out
of politics like we we were sort of all
over the place whether we were talking
about what the nature of reality is or
sex or weed or whatever so it was kind
of everywhere but we'll continue the
conversation look I suspect if Bill was
to answer that question honestly which I
think he would of course he wants he
wants the best possible possible
oncologist you want the best possible
doctor you don't care about someone's
skin color and you don't care
necessarily about their moral fiber but
when when you're the one that's laying
on the table you want to know that you
have the best person possible right we
all want the best pilot in the plane uh
not somebody who is based you know based
on their gender or you know somebody who
is incompetent or you know they're
competent you want somebody sorry you
want somebody who's competent as a pilot
and if they're you know cheating on
their wife it's actually not that
relevant to them flying a plane it's
just how it is Larry says have you ever
met a Scientologist
you know
I don't know actually uh no no no that's
not true I for sure I've met
scientologists here and there actually
when we did our show when we were on
tour and we did our show up in uh what's
up by Tampa what's the Clearwater thank
you that's where the uh the main Church
of Scientology is so I met a bunch of
people afterwards who were
scientologists and a few people were
like we thought you were going to make
fun of scientologists the whole time you
didn't thank you thank you
um I've never met Tom Cruise uh you know
I've chatted with Kirstie Alley of it
she's a Scientologist so there you go
schmoo says do you really think World
War III is on the horizon or is this
just more Russia Russia Russia midterm
election hype to scare the crap out of
those who have lost the art of critical
rational thinking
well a let me be clear about this one I
don't want World War III I would prefer
that nukes not be dropped and I think if
we could all just pause on everything
stop giving money to the area really
figure out what's going on here if Biden
could sit down with Putin not divided
knows what he's doing but like why
aren't we having peace Summits why
aren't we actually having any sort of
negotiation as a matter of fact Biden
said he wouldn't sit down with Putin you
may remember that from the Tapper
interview that we showed you a couple
days ago so we have all sorts of
problems there as I have said from the
beginning of this thing and I think this
thing is very very messy it's hard to
really understand what's going on there
I am not saying Russia is the good guy
you cannot invade a Sovereign Nation and
just take territory you cannot do it
there might be a certain amount of crime
people in Crimea who want to be part of
Mother Russia maybe they have to have a
referendum on that but it can't be done
by the by the barrel of a gun
and there might be other providences
same thing they have certain things to
work out my main issue with this I have
two sort of issues with this number one
it's hard to know what I have three
issues number one it's just hard to know
what's going on over there and what's
honestly true uh number two right now
with every screwy thing that we have
going on in this country do we have all
of this money just to be thrown in there
and how come when we give them 12
million dollars we don't discuss whether
it's going to be equitably uh shared
amongst people of color of Ukraine not
that many people of color in Ukraine but
when we do things here it all has to be
equity-based and we have to make sure
you're going to chop someone's genitals
off uh and then of course the third one
is that to constantly say we're winning
and we're arming Ukraine and they're
winning
the end of the day with
that guy in the situation has nuclear
weapons you better not tell him he's
losing no matter what because he might
just do something crazy so it is it's a
little hard to tell how much of this is
real how much of it's sort of a media
concoction and just in in you know sort
of world geopolitics things just subtly
can spin out of control things just can
spin out of control so you got to be
careful you got to be careful uh Sarah
says who would be your top three for
POTUS if all conservative podcasters
were in the race uh for example Crowder
Shapiro Prager Glenn back Etc well I
think Prager would be an unbelievably
good president of the United States I
think his his ability to explain the
goodness of this country and the
goodness of people uh the fact that he
always goes out of his way to extend his
hand to liberals
um I think you know he's written so much
about where this country came from and
why we are still The Shining Beacon and
all that stuff I think he would be great
I think he could be it do it in a
diplomatic way
you know Shapiro might be a little too
acerbic for it uh you know Glenn would
be you know it's like these are all good
people to a certain extent but like if
I'm really honestly answering the
question out of that crew that you just
mentioned there and we could throw in
obviously a couple other people Candace
Etc et cetera I think Prager probably
would be the most sensible one uh but
Dennis is 74. yeah he's enjoying his
life right now I think he feels like
he's doing the right thing and prageru
has been incredibly influential I don't
sense that I actually think there might
have been a window for it a couple years
ago and of course people ask him to do
all the time Jordan Peterson would be
interesting you know like I don't see
him as a politician but can you imagine
can you imagine Jordan Peterson as
president of the United States could be
wild uh Deep Thoughts says there seems
to be so many loose ends with regard to
Trump and what Biden has done in 18
months to damage a formerly functional
country I can't remember ever feeling
this stressed about my country do you
think we can finally close some of the
open questions with definitive answers
and solve some of the current problems
now or ever after the midterms not till
2024 well first off on the stress issue
because everyone's feeling stressed to
some degree like you know when you feel
like you can't buy things you know you
go to the store and either they don't
have things that they used to have or
the prices are too high or you're
feeling that your bank account isn't
where it should be and like that that
just general feeling
the dollar is not stretching the way it
used to that that's a bad feeling that
you take with you kind of all the time
then you throw in all the stuff around
education and wokeness and then people
are sending their kids to school and
they don't know what their kids are
learning about you throw in as we just
talked about this very bizarre Russia
Ukraine situation
um you throw in censorship like there's
so many things that are happening in our
modern lives that that feel out of whack
but I would say you know you know I
bring a fart all the time but I live in
a place that's very functional and when
I close my phone and I just spend time
out here in the community or I'm working
with people that are you know doing some
work at the house or meeting people on
the street or whatever it's like there's
an awful lot of good people out there
there's places where it is functional
and good and and I think the problem is
we've all become so obsessed with the
federal government and that the
president somehow is supposed to be king
which of course it's actually intended
to be the reverse of that we were
fleeing the power of a tyrannical King
we're
so obsessed with all of that that it
makes everything feel
scary and depressing all the time and
all of those things it's why I try to do
the show the way that I do and I try to
make sure not to endlessly blast you
guys with with scare and fear-mongering
as as you can see they're doing
virtually every day on it well MSNBC and
the view and the rest of it they just
got to keep them scared because it's a
lot easier for whatever reason it is
something to do with human nature it's a
lot easier to keep people glued to that
freaking screen if they're scared rather
than empowered because empowered people
might get up and go do something for
themselves they really might I'm willing
to take that risk if we fix all of the
problems and there's nothing else to
talk about I'll get going I'm not going
to tell you where I'm going and
hopefully you guys will get going too
and we'll go well that was fun while it
lasted Nick says so your sons will be
growing up as Florida Miami natives will
you take advantage of the limited window
of their youth to teach them the
valuable skill of being bilingual that's
an interesting one so you know there's
obviously here in in Miami especially
Miami is such an international City you
hear so many different languages here
all the time obviously outside of
English Spanish is the main one yes I
would like to teach them a bit of
Spanish I can speak a little bit of
Spanish David's actually pretty good in
doing the Duolingo thing and yeah we've
our housekeepers who are also helping
out with the kids a little bit like they
uh they don't live with us but like when
they're here like they there's a little
Spanish going around like we're we're
trying like I think English is the
American language and it should always
remain the American language but I also
think just it's good for kids brains
like it's good for them to learn and
also you know the kids have that
malleability of the mind when they're
young it's very easy to teach kids
second and sometimes even third
languages when they're very young it
gets harder obviously as it gets as you
get a little bit older Greg says when
liberals move out of California will
they bring their politics Rogan now
lives in Texas has anyone asked him if
he will continue to vote for politicians
with Progressive policies do they accept
any responsibility for voting in the
very people destroying California look
if I ever do Rogan show again I'm sure
it'll happen at some point I will gladly
ask him that I think it's an incredibly
Rich place to talk about things
you know it's like you may have voted
the wrong way at one point in your life
maybe all of us have I certainly have or
made decisions put aside politics we've
all made mistakes in our life we've all
done the wrong thing in our life it
doesn't mean you always do it but you
have to kind of acknowledge
oh I did something wrong I screwed up on
this thing like that's the way you start
getting better as a human being
um I can tell you from the Florida
perspective I'm meeting an awful lot of
New Yorkers in Cali mostly who come down
here some Connecticut people too who
come down here and it's just very clear
like everyone's like I'm here to keep
Florida Florida I love Florida man I'll
wrestle an alligator to prove it like
people kind of get it down here
um I don't know that Rogan has said who
he would vote for in the in the
gubernatorial race in Texas whether it
is Greg Abbott who's the current
Republican Governor or whether he would
go with furry uh Beto O'Rourke I I would
certainly hope that he is not even
considering voting for Beto but it would
I guess it would be nice if he has not
said it already to say it uh and and
that's the that's the challenge for all
of these people like if you've really
fled a city if you fled a state over the
last two years because the lockdowns are
the economy or crime or homelessness it
really should be in you now why you did
it it really should be in you and I
think it is in most people I would say
that's a bit different than say 10 years
ago when usually people were leaving for
financial reasons right you're going to
get your people who retire who then want
to you know they don't have as much
money to spend so they want lower taxes
you're going to get people who are
making a ton of money and then they
realize that they're going to lose a lot
of New York or Cali or whatever and then
they still vote in the bad things
because a lot of times liberals can't
connect all of the policies to the to
the results so I do sense it's different
this time like reality smacked a whole
bunch of liberals in the face and uh if
you're if you're a gobsmacked liberal
who's living in Texas or Tennessee or
Florida you better know why uh sisito
says congratulations on baby two what
did Bill Maher say that most surprised
you
you know we got into this thing about
about meaning and the universe and and
signs and reality and all this and you
know I tell him this story about how the
universe can talk to you sometimes and I
relate this story if you haven't seen it
yet just just watch the video about
um about my grandma and lightning
striking her apartment and it on the
anniversary of her death and some stuff
happened and he just his whole thing is
that you know he's an atheist his whole
thing is that it's all random everything
is random and he calls the show club
random it's all completely random I it's
funny to me that the atheists who you
would think would be a little more
open-minded like no it's it's just not
all random it's just not and you would
think that the free thinkers might at
least put some they may not go okay I
like the Bible but you might want to
have some Curious interesting view of
what the world is uh in any event ladies
and gentlemen that is our show for
Friday uh join us by subscribing at
rumble.com Ruben reported
reubenreport.locos.com and I will see
you on Monday